[Musique]
un bon soir jeudi 17 septembre le 7-8
journal de tv 78 pour un condensé
d'actualité locale bienvenue dans cette
édition voici les titres
le tour de france 2020 bientôt l
épilogue la dernière étape s'élancera
dimanche depuis mantes-la-jolie
direction les champs elysées c'est la
troisième fois d'affilée que la grande
boucle passe par les yvelines ce sera le
cas jusqu'en 2023 invité michel callot
président de la fédération française de
cyclisme
samedi c'est laisser la 6ème journée
mondiale pour le don de moelle osseuse
chaque année en france 2000 personnes
ont besoin d'une greffe et dans ce
journal le témoignage d'une habitante de
bois d'arcy elle a reçu un don en 2019
lui permettant de combattre sa leucémie
et puis la page consacrée à la
législative partielle dont la 11e
circonscription premier tour ce dimanche
20 septembre
onze candidats sont engagés laurent
morin sera en plateau avec nous il est
en lice pour le rassemblement national
et puis ce qu'il faut retenir des as 37e
journées du patrimoine c'est à suivre
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
ce dimanche la dernière étape du tour de
france partira donc depuis les yvelines
122 km entre mantes-la-jolie et les
champs-elysées à paris est depuis 2012
c'est la cinquième fois que la grande
boucle passe dans les yvelines avec deux
étapes chaque année du paris-nice le
vélodrome ou encore de nombreuses pistes
cyclables et les yvelines sont depuis
2010 9 terre d'excellence de vélo les
précisions de mélanie poké des mondiaux
de pestant 2015 d europe en 2016 le
départ de paris nice depuis 2010 ou
encore le tour de france le cyclisme
rythme la vie sportive yvelinoise mais
les sportifs de haut niveau ne sont pas
les seuls à profiter des routes et
chemins
aujourd'hui c'est près de 850 km plus de
600 à 850 km de pistes cyclables
développer dans le département qui nous
permet de relier à la fois tous nos
lieux culturels de relier nos villes de
relier nos espaces et puis de rendre
aussi encore une fois ce département
attractif ce département vert on est en
train de travailler avec une et dix
aussi par exemple pour essayer de
trouver des solutions pour pouvoir
accompagner des bornes de recharge aussi
sur le vélo sur le vélo électrique une
présence de la discipline qui permet à
la fédération française de cyclisme de
récompenser le département 2019 les
yvelines sont reconnus terre
d'excellence du cyclisme en territoire
que se partagent 27 clubs
le vélo club et long cours saint quentin
en yvelines recense 140 adhérents des
jeunes prometteurs et des pistards
confirmé vraiment la piste il avait été
ma route des chiffres hausse la
prochaine étape
enfin tu n'existes pas une passion pour
la petite reine qui devrait durer au
minimum jusqu'en 2024 le département
accueillera les épreuves cyclistes pour
les jeux olympiques et michel callot le
président de la fédération française de
cyclisme doit être avec nous en visio
pour une interview n'a pas encore
rejoint
journal nous essayons de le joindre au
cours de cette édition juste un mot
avant d'enchaîner sur autre chose sur le
tour de france avec plusieurs routes qui
seront bloqués dimanche avec la grande
boucle qui passe par plusieurs villes
des yvelines notamment à fontenay le
fleury et saint cyr l'école de communes
où les habitants sont appelés aux urnes
pour une législative partielle dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines des
perturbations sont donc à prévoir de
14h30 à 17h30 la préfecture des yvelines
recommande donc à ses habitants de venir
voter avant 14 heures ou après 18 heures
les bureaux de vote seront ouverts
jusqu'à 20h dans l'actualité aussi les
chiffres du comité 19 qui repartent en
légère hausse dans les yvelines hier
mercredi on recensait à 5
hospitalisations supplémentaires est
deux en réanimation et deux décès à
l'hôpital à la stratégie vous le savez
pour contrer la propagation en plus des
mesures barrières c'est de tester
massivement dans les prochains jours
plusieurs dépistages gratuits se déroule
dans les yvelines on va voir le
programme s'afficher demain agences
régionales de santé installera ses
tentes sur la place des combattants à
saint-germain-en-laye c'est de 10h à 18h
samedi c'est la région ile de france par
le biais de son camion le mobile test
qui se rendra à triel sur seine et
mantes la ville pour des tests aussi
bien un pcr que sérologique
enfin une vingtaine d'opérations de
dépistage se sont déjà tenues dans les
yvelines se chiffre à présent en 2000 le
nombre de français qui ont besoin chaque
année d'une greffe de moelle osseuse
samedi c'est la 6ème journée mondiale
consacrée à ces dons c'est aussi une
date anniversaire pour cette arcisienne
il ya 18 mois fabienne de girardi
recevait un don lui permettant de
combattre sa leucémie
son témoignage recueilli par mélanie
poké elle est aujourd'hui en rémission
mais doit encore patienter pour
s'estimer guéri
cette maman de deux garçons adolescents
découvrent en novembre 2018 qu'elle est
atteinte d'une leucémie un choc
forcément puisque dès qu'on prononce le
mot leucémie égale cancer on sait que
tout de suite on sait qu'on risque de
mourir
donc oui c'est d'abord un choc en même
temps c'est un soulagement parce que moi
avec les maux de tête que j'avais
j'étais intimement convaincu qu'il ya
quelque chose qui tournait pas rond
hospitalisé d'urgence à l'hôpital mignot
de versailles fabienne ans
une chimiothérapie 24 heures sur 24
pendant 15 jours les médecins ne lui
diront jamais que le pronostic est
mauvais mais ne lui cache pas qu'il faut
procéder à une greffe de moelle osseuse
on interroge le fichier international de
donneurs les gens qu'on appelle les
veilleurs de vie et heureusement que le
fichier est internationale parce que
malheureusement dans notre pays on
compte environ 300 milles d'honneur
alors que les pays comme l'angleterre
l'allemagne ont jusqu'à trois ou quatre
millions de donneurs il faut savoir que
trouver un donneur sur le registre
international c'est une chance sur un
million
un donneur miraculeux que les médecins
trouveront en angleterre fabienne ne
connaîtra de lui que sa date de
naissance mais fille unique elle
s'identifie très vite mon donneur rien
d'en parler forcément c'est assez
émouvant parce que c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un qui ne vous connaît pas du
tout qui fait ça sans savoir qui y va
aider probablement qu'on lui a dit que
j'étais une femme que j'avais des
enfants
mais c'est vrai que oui du coup lui ne
connaîtra jamais mais moi qui n'ai
jamais eu de frère par exemple sachant
que maintenant c'est son sang qui
circule dans mes veines
donc maintenant j'ai son adn dans mes
veines
oui pour moi c'est un frère professeurs
des écoles fabien de girardi n'a pas
encore retrouvé sa classe
aujourd'hui elle partage son expérience
pour appeler aux dons dans quatre ans
elle saura si elle est véritablement
guéri en bref le procureur de la
république de versailles s'est exprimé
dans les colonnes du parisien au sujet
de la sphère mamadou fofana ce père de
famille de 35 ans qui est mort noyé dans
la seine dimanche à bougival ils étaient
poursuivis par des policiers soupçonnés
d'un vol de moto maryvonne caillibotte
se défend des accusations de partialité
dans cette affaire la famille et
l'avocat de la victime soutiennent aussi
que les policiers ont tué volontairement
mamadou fofana et maryvonne caillibotte
a annoncé l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire pour recherche des causes de
la mort
rien est obscur ou dissimulé at elle
assuré en promettant de faire toute la
lumière sur les faits
ce week-end ce sont les 37e journée du
patrimoine malgré quelques annulations
liées au contexte sanitaire
l événement se tiendra bien dans
plusieurs communes des yvelines la
sélection des animations phares à faire
à saint quentin en yvelines avec astrid
bergère dans les yvelines de nombreuses
animations auront lieu pour les trente
septième journée du patrimoine
parmi elles une visite originale de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la compagnie à une paix hull
agence nationale de psychanalyse urbaine
qui s'en chargera l'idée est de
découvrir sous un autre angle les lieux
où l'on passe tous les jours on se rend
pas vraiment quand en fait de tout ce
que l'on dit en regardant sur
l'environnement toujours sous le mans
sous la main sous le même angle pardon
est là l'idée c'est vraiment de décaler
drogue le regard et de se dire en fait
comment se fait-il que je n'ai pas vu
cette chose qui sous mes yeux
le point de rendez vous est donné au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
14h30 le samedi 19 et le dimanche 20
les organisateurs rappellent que la
réservation est obligatoire et que les
participants marcheront deux à trois
kilomètres
autre événement coup de coeur ce
week-end des spectacles de danse
verticale
ça veut dire que c'est une danse qui est
ouverte est possible pour tous les âges
absolument et pas seulement pour les des
grands habitués la danse contemporaine
mais vraiment pour tous les publics
l'idée dé cette pratique c'est
d'utiliser les murs des édifices ou des
bâtiments pour danser la ville pour nous
est un espace qui est complètement
ouvert à notre notre danse et en plus on
quelque part on invente un nouvel usage
à la ville puisque
on vient on arrive avec nos cordes no
baudriller tout ce matériel d'escaladé
mais avec un avec une recherche
chorégraphique des spectacles de danse à
découvrir à montigny le bretonneux et à
elancourt et pour tout savoir des
journées du patrimoine et aussi à d
autres idées de sorties dans le
département ne manquez pas ce soir le
retour du 7-8 loisirs l'émission débute
sa saison avec célia gars de son go à la
présentation c'est à suivre à partir de
18h30 pour refermer cette édition la
page dédiée à la législative partielle
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
onze candidats sont sur la ligne de
départ vous voyez leur nom s'afficher un
scrutin rendu nécessaire après la
démission de nadia qui est entré au
gouvernement devenu ministre délégué à
la ville premier tour le dimanche 20
septembre c'est dimanche prochain un
éventuel deuxième tour et dimanche 27
septembre et laurent morin est avec mon
plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
candidat du rassemblement national pour
cette législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines vous êtes
le tout récent responsable du rnd dans
le département et vous avez été aussi
élu pendant un mandat à mantes-la-ville
vous étiez le premier adjoint derrière
cyril notamment de la ville de 2014 à
2020 c'était la seule commune le précise
détenu par le rn en ile de france
pourquoi être candidat dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines vous qui
êtes plutôt du nord des yvelines du coup
eh bien je crois que les électeurs ont
droit à de multiples candidatures bien
entendu quelle qu'elle soit je crois que
le rassemblement national et ma
candidature est finalement la seule
alternative qui puisse résoudre un
certain nombre de problèmes qui se font
jour
aujourd'hui en france et la question que
les électeurs doivent se poser c'est
pourquoi continuerait-il à voter pour
les responsables qui nous qui ont acquis
ont amené finalement la france au bord
du gouffre il faut savoir que le
le mandat des manuels macron a été une
succession d'affaires la sphère el
guerrab du nom de ce journaliste qui a
frappé avec son casque un autre député
la sphère benalla bien entendu la sphère
bayrou la sphère de rugy la fere nadia
et qui provoque cette élection
législative partielle
voilà pour les affaires mais de manière
plus générale c'est le chaos généralisé
qui s'installe en france nous avons eu
les gilet jaune
nous avons eu une gestion catastrophique
de l'épidémie du coronavirus et donc je
pense que il faut présenter une
alternative crédible et sérieuse à ce
mandat qui est un échec et je veux
ajouter également que les républicains
ne sont pas en reste puisque les
républicains ont également eu aussi
participé à un certain nombre de
gouvernements ils sont co responsables
de l'effondrement de la france au niveau
départemental les républicains avec il
faut bien le dire et je suis désolé de
löw de le rappeler
je pense notamment aux électeurs et aux
adhérents et l'eire qui pourrait très
bien nous rejoindre parce que le
département des yvelines est quand même
dirigé par un repris de justice qui mène
une politique clientéliste et
antisociales antisocial pourquoi parce
qu'il faut bien rappeler qu'en 2016
le président du conseil départemental à
augmenter la taxe foncière de 66%
et bien entendu c'est une attaque contre
le pouvoir d'achat sont vos propos on
sent un petit peu du contexte de cette
11e circonscription
c'est tout de même une circonscription
le rn à peu la faveur des électeurs 3 2
5 % en 2007 à 8 3% en 2012 7% lors de la
dernière législative en 2017
du coup quel est l'objectif fixé pour ce
scrutin est est ce que vous y croyez du
coup vu le contexte un peu particulier
aussi de cette élection
alors c'est vrai que ce territoire n'est
généralement pas très favorable à notre
mouvement
le contexte particulier de cette
élection partielle ajoute ajoute
peut-être à
à la problématique parce qu'un certain
nombre d'électeurs peut-être ne vont pas
être intéressé à ce scrutin les jeux et
je le regrette et d'ailleurs je les
appelle tous les électeurs y compris les
abstentionnistes parce que je peux
comprendre qu'effectivement dans ce
contexte les abstentionnistes puisse
être désabusés par un certain nombre de
comportements politiques
mais il est vrai que il faut qu'il fasse
jouer alors leur droit de vote à fond
c'est leur qualité de vie et leur mode
de vie qui est en jeu et je rebondis sur
ce que vous disiez sur le fait que en
parlant du conseil départemental ça
n'est pas tout à fait l'enjeu de la
législative partielle
monsieur pierre benassaya philippe
benassaya lapsus philippe benassaya fait
partie quand même de l'équipe du conseil
départemental de la majorité de pierre
bédier
donc il a validé l'augmentation de la
taxe foncière de 60%
il valide également les investissements
qui sont faits en afrique dont la jud
dans la dans la chambre régionale des
comptes dit qu'ils sont opaques
il a validé également ce projet de
fusion anti démocratique avec les
hauts-de-seine donc finalement tous ces
sujets ont à voir avec avec cette
législative partielle
et justement le disait ya un contexte
particulier souhaite une circonscription
où les électeurs votent peu il y avait à
moins d'un électeur sur deux lors de la
dernière législative dans cette 11e
circonscription forcément un contexte
particulier avec aussi cette rentrée
c'est pas allés voter allez mettre un
bulletin dans l'urne n'est pas forcément
la priorité pour les évidences monde
comment vous comptez les convaincre
comment aller à la rencontre des
événements avec avec le masque parce que
c'est un petit peu plus difficile aussi
d'aller à la rencontre de ces événements
oui alors c'est vrai que le contexte
sanitaire fait que la campagne est très
difficile moi j'ai décidé de ne pas
faire de réunions publiques bien entendu
pour ne pas ajouter du risque ou risque
les rencontres effectivement dans la rue
ne sont pas non plus naturel à cause
d'eux
de la présence du masque etc pour
convaincre les électeurs je pense qu'il
faut parler de leurs préoccupations
et on peut dire que cet été la
préoccupation majeure c'est
l'ensauvagement il y a eu une série de
faits dont on a du mal à imaginer qu'il
puisse se produire dans notre dans notre
pays
je pense à ce chauffeur de bus de
bayonne qui a été tué en faisant son
travail je pense à sept gendarmes qui a
été percuté par un automobiliste dans le
sud de la france je pense à cette aide
soignante également à lyon vous êtes
d'accord avec le constat fait par le
mille donateurs qui en ont sauvagement
aujourd'hui la lan c'était surtout le
ministre de l'intérieur qui est en
accord avec le constat que le
rassemblement fait nationale fait depuis
40 ans c'est à dire que nous avions
prévu de très longue date que nous en
arriverions à 7 à cette situation de
pré-guerre civile
donc je crois que pour résoudre ce
problème il faut d'abord faire confiance
à ceux qui qui regarde la vérité en face
et qui ne sont pas dans le béni parce
que malheureusement le déni et est une
des causes de cette en sauvage mans et
il faut ensuite mettre des mesures en
place comme par exemple supprimer les
aides sociales aux parents des enfants
mineurs multirécidivistes
il faut expulser les délinquants et les
criminels étrangers comme cela se
pratique dans n'importe quel pays vous
allez moi j'ai beaucoup voyagé et j'ai
beaucoup voyagé dans des pays dont on
disait à l'époque qu'ils étaient les
pays du tiers-monde moi je ne considère
pas ainsi mais je peux vous dire que
dans ces pays là lorsqu'un délinquant
lorsque quelqu'un on pratique la
délinquance ou s'adonnent à la
criminalité en étrangers deux de ces
pays là il est expulsé donc de conclure
ce qu'on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien
mais merci merci d'être venu le roman je
rappelle que vous êtes le candidat du
rassemblement national pour cette
législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription premier tour ce dimanche
et je vous le disais on ce candidat en
tout dans cette circonscription pour ce
scrutin présentation à présent de
laurent en caux jetons qui porte la
candidature de l'union populaire
républicaine
je suis candidat on fait pour redonner à
la france sa liberté son indépendance
elle a débarrassé de la corruption des
conflits d'intérêts des lobbys des
sociétés secrètes qui la grangrène ainsi
que de l'union européenne qui nous fait
perdre notre souveraineté et notre
démocratie
juste la découverte de l'upper j'étais
dégoûtée par la politique française tous
partis confondus
j'étais un abstentionniste et je ne
pensais plus que je pourrai un jour
connaître un parti intègre qui dit la
vérité aux français et qui représente
vraiment le peuple
[Musique]
j'ai fait cinq points différents
le premier ça serait la défense d'une
démocratie plus directe en faisant appel
au référendum sur les questions
importantes telles que leclerc
l'immigration la bête jeu proposera
également un véritable référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ou populaire avec
un seuil de déclenchement de cinq cent
mille signatures soit à peu près 1,5
pour cent du corps électoral
la deuxième idée est très importante
c'est l'assainissement de la classe
politique française par l'inéligibilité
à vie de tout élu condamné dans les
acides dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
je demanderai également l'obligation
pour tous les élus ou membres de
l'exécutif de procéder à casier
judiciaire vierge
il paraît un minimum plus vu qu'on
demande pour beaucoup de professions je
lancerai aussi un référendum pour
demander aux français s'ils souhaitent
le maintien de la france dans l'union
européenne
je proposerai aux français le lancement
de la procédure de disques de
destitution de macros pour violations
répétées de la constitution
j'ai une cinquième idées phares je
proposerai la reconnaissance pleine et
entière du vote blanc il sera
révocatoire
[Musique]
les abidal c'est à dire parce que je
représente le seul parti qui soit
vraiment d'opposition en france
les autres partis de l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche ne sont que de fausses
d'opposition ou des oppositions contrôle
et vous aurez avec moi l'occasion de
donner votre voix à un candidat qui aime
la france et les français et qui se
placera en véritables opposants
amat ronde qui a été mis en place par
les médias et les puissances financières
pour d'être à la france est violente et
les français donc j'appelle tous les
dégoûtés de la politique les
abstentionnistes à découvrir notre
mouvement de libération nationale et à
me soutenir en allant voter avec lui
perd 3 aura enfin d'où l'importance et
ne manquez pas ce soir le débat entre
les candidats dans cette 11e
circonscription c'est à 22h et non à 20
heures comme je vous l'avais annoncé
hier on a réussi à établir la connexion
très rapidement pour la fin de ce
journal avec michel callot bonsoir
bonsoir président de la fédération
française de cyclisme on avait tout à
l'heure un sujet qui parlait des
yvelines comme terre de cyclisme
juste une question je vous fait réagir
et on va devoir rendre l'antenne ensuite
pourquoi à votre avis les les yvelines
sont elles si propice au cyclisme
pourquoi c'est une terre de cyclisme
quand je pense que les événements ont
beaucoup d'atouts déjà il ya des
équipements à commencer par dans le
vélodrome par le stadium dmx par
l'ensemble des pistes et des voies
cyclables qui facilitent la pratique du
vélo
donc ça c'est un élément important et
puis un autre atout sans doute marquant
pour les yvelines et bien c'est sa
position géographique aux portes de de
l'île de france en tout les cas
permettant à un accès en milieu un petit
peu moins urbanisées qui est plus
propice aux vélos sous une forme
sportive quelle que soit sa forme que ce
soit sur ou tout que ce soit dans l'est
dans les chemins avec le vtt par exemple
bien merci pour ce mot rapide michel
callot président de la fédération
française de cyclisme merci de nous
avoir rejoints tout de même pour la fin
de ce journal et je rappelle cette étape
du tour de france dernières étapes au
programme dimanche entre mantes-la-jolie
et les champs-elysées voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de votre fidélité
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]